we're not importing it just like we
didn't import
Eugenics we didn't get any of that stuff
from Germany until after the war when we
did Operation Paperclip that that came
from us I contend if we lose our way now
our technology will make us the the
greatest evil force ever on the face of
the Earth
um and you you look at these all these
companies that have such high ESG scores
yet you're in bed with China and you're
willing to write anything for China you
don't care about the slaves please don't
talk to me about slavery in 1850 when
you are writing programs to enslave
people today in China
we are
we are now entering territories and we
talk about it in in the book dark future
where
where it's almost these mad scientists
who are so reckless on
um AI or AGI or ASI that they
they they feel like they're I think they
feel like they're making a God and they
so want to talk and Converse and be in
the presence of omnipotence that they'll
create it and somehow or another they
think they'll be okay
we have no idea we are dealing with an
alien life
uh and
I mean I I've seen the movies this isn't
a good thing that you just run into
okay so I think some people are waking
up to it certainly your audience is is
hearing this stuff my audience we we
talk about this and you know clearly
there's been some pushback a guy like
Glenn Younkin one in Virginia because he
stood up against you know stood up for
the parents and things things of that
nature but let's connect this a little
bit to some of the stuff the books about
in the title again which because I'm a
big sci-fi guy dark future I mean it
just sounds like a movie that I would
have run to have seen with
Schwarzenegger in you know 1987.
um
because now so much of our information
is sorted by machines Nai and you just
mentioned you're hanging out with a
bunch of artists right now I mean
artists are going to be hanging on by a
thread now with AI art it's crazy I
don't know if you've gone on to any of
those sites where you can basically just
put in a couple keywords and come up
with art that is to be honest incredibly
unbelievably inspiring and awesome and
it's not re you know in essence it's not
real like we're just running behind
machines almost at every front right now
so and it hasn't even begun we are we
are now at the very beginning of What's
called the fourth Industrial Revolution
the fourth Industrial Revolution is
going to take the the first Industrial
Revolution began in 1760 1770 somewhere
in that so imagine what life was like in
1770 you're still crapping Outdoors
there is no such thing as a sales
manager
um there's no electricity it's
not great uh all of the changes from the
first Industrial Revolution until about
1880 where we discover electricity and
we get refrigeration and lights and
everything else to the uh to the
information age and the Space Age then
the third is the technological uh
difference in the information age really
kind of coming together
all of that from 1770 to about 2020
that whole change that kind of an impact
is going to happen in the next 10 years
and the displacement is going to be
uh Beyond
understanding the problem is we could
make this we could absolutely make this
if we had governments anywhere in the
world telling people the truth right
they're telling you about climate change
that's bullcrap and even if it isn't
bullcrap it's at least a hundred years
away okay and we could technologically
figure out ways to to best it in the end
man will survive
but what they're not telling you is your
life is about to dramatically change to
where the uh people like Yuval Noah
Harari is uh he's talking about useless
classes millions and millions of people
in a useless class that can't do
anything but eat
um let me pause you there for a second
because what do you make of a guy like
him he's big sort of in the wef circles
and a lot of people hate him but in an
odd way you just said he's telling us a
very dark truth that there is yeah he is
absolutely right you need to pay
attention to him but uh let's not take
any final solutions from him right uh
you know it doesn't you know you can be
right diagnosing the problem it doesn't
make you right uh in the solution
um and he is he is with too many people
that I mean this is very malthusian
what's happening at the wef
um you know everybody still loves George
Bernard Shaw for some reason but he's
the guy who first came up with a gas
chamber he's the guy who said there's
got to be an easier way to kill groups
of people because they're not useful to
us and they have no reason to live
um thank you thank you America's
greatest playwright
um but uh or English playwright
um
they're going down the same road we I I
believe Dave
we are seeing now
all of the things the Nazis wanted to do
we are now technologically able to do
we're able to make the Uber man we are
able to weed out the incorrect genes
we're able to round people up and
categorize them quickly I mean the only
reason why Germans were so effective in
killing Jews was because of IBM IBM it
developed the punch card system IBM was
at the concentration camps every week
working on on their computers they knew
what was going on imagine what could be
done today
that doesn't mean it has to happen it
just means I don't see a lot of our
better angels in powerful positions
so when you see the what I would
describe is as uh weakness or actual
connection to China
weakness against China or connection to
China say from the Biden Administration
and then you see what's going on in
China right now social credit 15-minute
cities uh you know people's face you do
you do something that they don't want
you to do your face is now blasted in
effect in Times Square of China all day
long so people know not to associate
with you it is quite literally an
episode of Black Mirror which I
recommend everyone watch but basically
the book is is telling us this is what
we're importing right now
oh so we're not importing it just like
we didn't import
um
Eugenics we didn't get any of that stuff
from Germany until after the war when we
did Operation Paperclip that came from
us I contend if we lose our way now our
technology will make us the the greatest
evil force ever on the face of the Earth
um and you you look at these all these
companies that have such high ESG scores
yet you're in bed with China and you're
willing to write anything for China you
don't care about the slaves please don't
talk to me about slavery in 1850 when
you are writing programs to enslave
people today in China
we are
we are now entering territories and we
talk about it in in the book dark future
um where
where it's almost these mad scientists
who are so reckless on
um AI or AGI or ASI that they
they they feel like they're I think they
feel like they're making a God and they
so want to talk and Converse and be in
the presence of omnipotence that they'll
create it and somehow or another they
think they'll be okay
we have no idea we are dealing with an
alien life
uh and
I mean I I've seen the movies this isn't
a good thing that you just run into you
know it's funny I'm listening to you and
again I'm a huge sci-fi guy the list of
sci-fi movies that have predicted all of
this whether it's the machines taking
over or the algorithms taking over or or
quite literally the last couple Alien
movies where they're trying to create
the the perfect organism and of course
the organism is going to realize guess
what I don't need you and therein lies
the rub if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of mindless
dribble check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell